HAS AMERICAN SUPPORT STARTEDIAI?
'S B NEWS FIRST  PF WEARING TIEV
THLOOFAINIAN F GOLD,O OWY ORL W
SI LY COVE GOT TO B BILE.BU
SPEECHAS
E AND
GOLD O ON. I
UKRAIN% BACK IICAN 32%M N  MIDR
McCARTHY, POTENTIATH
S WIL OUSE, AITOKELYDWINDLHE SAG
TO BE SITTININ AND
BLANK CHECK TO UKRAINE
DAY TE
HERITAGEION,THE ROOMN
OGPUTIN.TIOVFO
ONOFFICIAL TOL
DENCY ONT" BECAUSE O
FEELS USASRRITORY ASRY
POSSIBLE BEFORE SUS ARE
FACTORS  H E WINTER.ILL GA CONGS
PE THEY BLACKM.
NT
IS SPORTANT.LESS, THE UKRAINIAUI
VICTORY ASEEESEARCH BY
MY NEXT GUEST.
JOINING ME NOWS MOHA
EDITO CHIEF O
ENTLD TH IS
IT TO GET NFFROM UKRNECHS R-
GRESTIONE TECHNOLOGYALLYCHN THE
PHONESCRS THCOABLE
TOFELTBAS REGION THIS PO
DA WOULD  US USEFUL IMAE THE TIH
AME UKRAINIAN PUBLIC
WEOME ONG
THEM U SCREEYOU FOUNDING THAT %
SAID T SHOULL IT WINS
STO YR DATA
RESOLVE.
Y THATID WHA
HAS FAILED TO D ITS CONFLICTS E
WHAT DS WINNING
IN
WANT TR COUNTRWI TERRITORY L201
RE IT IS, 91ID VICTORY
WOULILAN FORCES
RETAKIA
HAIN 201
CRU
DO DFEOCUSEDERNMOSGI
PUTIN IS LAYAIM TO AND
HE W                    REUM DF.
EOS FATIGUE IS VY  PUTHORCE  ACI
IDENT.F SUPPOR  L KYIV ISVIDENT
GIONS,
VIEWS THAT YOUA MINU O.O,ELD
EXPECT THEIR CNT
WHEN THE CONFLICT ESSENTIALLY
STARTED ABOUAT I, HOW
IT EXPECTED,
TH HEAVILY.
SO NOW AY OF THEIN THAY EXPECT O
E EXPRESTH
PA O THEY'NT TULD BE AREUTEGITIM
>> CONCLUDIT
A POLLAT
ANT FOR USSEAIN OF
THE DATA REALLY HIGH
THERIENCD PEINEAST
MAE UNDERLYING LENGESNA
WITHIN THENTRY.NG THINKT'S
TT O
EXPECT U.SSUONNUAND I WANT U.S..
CONTINUINTO AINE THROUGH ALICT
SOMEW
FARFETCHED FOR ONE REASON.TY OF
LODA